i gotta say one of the one of the one of
the highlights of 2020 was watching
chris with a beer go through his spam
comments
just
i'm always on the hunt for like
ridiculous comments
and we certainly had a few like uh on
the second day of the road trip we did
somebody told me i was disrespectful for
not enjoying the taste of the bee lava
yeah yeah yeah we didn't we didn't like
it yeah yeah he was sick
and someone said you're disrespectful to
the japanese for not liking hornet
larvae
but the woman
it's not like you said to her oh this
looks [ __ ] disgusting
it was it was really weird that sort of
comment triggered me that triggered me
right it was it was a trigger wow
as if as if that person commenting was
like well i personally love bee larvae
how dare you
the hornet lava my family's been
producing bee lava for generations i'll
have you know
i'm a third generation bee lobby
harvester oh it's like
like foreign folks who feel they need to
defend japan often come up a lot in my
comments and
uh yeah but people like that i find
usually haven't they've never actually
traveled to your bank right yeah
i have never traveled outside of their
country yeah like it's got nothing to do
with their
like i would understand a little more if
it was a japanese person
who was getting offended for japanese
culture right that makes sense
but usually it's like it's not it's just
people being like
woke you know yeah like i remember um
back when i was living in thailand like
my mom tried to get sydney to wear like
this very traditional thai dress
and sydney was like um yeah i don't know
about that because like a lot of people
can get offended because of like
cultural appropriation and stuff like
that
and my mum was like what's cultural
appropriation
and like having to explain the concept
of cultural appropriation
was just completely [ __ ] impossible
to like it's like a
you know like a asian mum right because
it just it just like
did not compute that why would anyone
get offended on behalf
of mike yeah of me oh it's because
before the word cultural appropriation
came about it was called cultural
appreciation you know
and now there's such a thin line between
what is appreciation and what is
appropriate
right yeah it's if you take too much you
know right it's like
is a white person wearing a kimono is
that appreciation or is that appropriate
someone started shagging sheep i would
be like hold on that's my thing
i think a lot of the time like you said
it's the the people themselves are like
yeah
dude we want you to experience our
culture we want you to share it right
like
it's like a [ __ ] all these like
people who are you know when ghost
tsushima came out so many people are
like oh this game is
it's such cultural appropriation to you
know the whole like samurai culture
thing
people said that yeah yeah yeah when the
game first came out i saw there was this
huge thing about it and
it was really funny because there was a
guy who gathered a bunch of uh
uh reviews or like i guess like you know
customer reviews of japanese people who
play the game and they were like
nah dude it's cool yeah yeah white
people please go ahead make a game about
samurais yeah
if it's like if they're obviously
respectful towards it who doesn't want a
[ __ ] video game about where they like
their history but there was this whole
thing of like oh it's a western company
making a game about japanese culture
it's like so if they can do it correctly
then what's the problem
how dare japanese people make bread
that's that's that's we made
we started there how dare they make our
bread
sorry i don't want to get like too like
anti-woke but you know yeah it's just
cursed you fall
it's just dumb i've seen like especially
recently just with the whole pc culture
thing it's just
there's no one can be culturally
appreciative of things anymore without
at least one person saying how dare you
that's offensive
right yeah i mean i think because it's
like it's like people want brownie
points on twitter right
right and because there are legitimate
cases of people just being shrimp
disrespectful
yeah yeah i think some people see that
and they're like oh
if i do that next time i'll get twitter
clout i'll get followers right so the
next opportunity that comes up they're
like immediately like on
it and then everyone's like well i mean
not really but that's the thing right
it's like
i you know you know bad intent when you
see it oh yeah yeah right and just some
people are just so clouded by that i
mean you think you know bad intent when
you see it but some people it feels like
it's some people are good at
bullshitting
intent is just lost in a lot of like in
a lot of cases and it's sometimes it's
just
hard especially on twitter and like you
said some people are like chasing for
this oh yeah because some people are
like
actively looking for any example that
they can they can see
and it's it's created a culture where
you know sometimes you want to do
something or you want to post something
on twitter but you don't know who's
going to offend sometimes right right um
yeah it's chris right yeah yeah it's a
tightrope in it
scared of saying anything yeah yeah i
don't know so
i like things and everyone right so i'll
be happy in 2021
let's be happy